can I has more interwebs not if the
government has anything to say about it
I'm here in the beautiful city of Austin
Texas for the South by Southwest
festival a time worth thousands upon
thousands of hipsters have descended
upon the city I've never seen so many
fedoras and creepy mustaches ironic
creepy mustaches more importantly tech
nerds have descended upon the city to
discuss the idea of net neutrality who
could be against net neutrality it
sounds wonderful it even has the words
neutrality in the name that's why nearly
everyone I asked supported it I'm
outside of the Austin Convention Center
where everything's going down we got
hipsters out here we'll see what they
know about that neutrality got my scruff
and my shirt they look like Kurt Cobain
cheering no
and then I found out they didn't
actually know what it was so seeing that
you work online um it's a big point of
discussion here in South by Southwest
what do you think of net neutrality
haven't heard of net neutrality what do
I think of it well it's a complicated
topic obviously I think it's easy to
distill complicated subjects like that
down jingoistic phrases um in terms of
access to to the pipes and everything
what do you think about net neutrality
mr. sac
Christopher Robin I'll start with you
yes
net neutrality you mean like censorship
I'll get him to talk I got some sodium
pentathol and the keys to Gitmo
net neutrality well I don't have an
official Dook Dook stance but my point
of view I support it C net neutrality is
about giving the government the right to
control and regulate the internet most
importantly regulating the speed at
which all data crosses networks
ultimately it's designed to ensure the
Equality of load time for all web sites
see the left is sphere with the
interwebs is that giant evil
corporations will take it over and
control it just ask Al Franken let me
say something about a corporation
fission power corporation is the big
corporations corporations corporations
corporations corporations of the
corporation
hoping to describe be very thing
the amazing such an important tool for
independent artists and entrepreneurs
it's freedom and openness see the
concern is that some Internet service
providers might favor some sites over
others giving them priority that would
mean that some high-volume sites might
be able to pay more for extra bandwidth
oh the humanity
there's only one problem it's never
happened so the one it seems to me the
key points you seem to hammer home there
what was really the sort of a threat of
corporations essentially allocating
bandwidth an information favoring graphs
some sites or some corporations nothing
to be the main concern would use that
kind of a silence absolutely the main
concerns that we lose the freedom to be
able to to create jobs create money
very disproportionate playing could you
cite a single case where that's happened
yet where that second via see she didn't
have an answer for that but let me
explain it to you through an example
let's use cell phones take here outside
of the South by Southwest Convention
Center where all the spouse's geeks
convening see all of them are
facebooking tweeting and using the South
by Southwest apps their little lonely
hearts content now because of that
service around this area is overburdened
excruciatingly Li slow and almost
unusable now most of these people are
using one of two things Twitter or the
South by Southwest app now let's say
hypothetically the AT&T wanted to they
could give this area in those sites
extra priority than say cute cats geo
cities calm then the vast majority of
people working here will be able to use
those applications seamlessly and get on
with their work but hypothetically let's
say they can't do that the government
steps in and says it's illegal and so
every other site runs just as slowly as
cute cats geo cities dot-com that's net
neutrality let's use another example say
the Postal Service let's say one person
wants to mail a letter now person number
two wants to mail a kettlebell
now you can't charge person number two
anymore to ship that heavy cumbersome
kettlebell and despite this elbow up
being easy to ship and relatively cheap
that envelope can't get there any more
quickly than the 50 pound kettlebell it
has to arrive at the same time to ensure
fairness that's net neutrality my back
so as you can imagine if everything has
to flow at the same speed the
kettlebells are more likely to bog down
the letters than anything else and by
that same token somebody who does
nothing but mail letters is still
burdened with the cost by the man who
mails nothing but kettlebells look this
is a metaphor I use for net neutrality
if you think of the Internet as a
communal freedom do you really want an
18-wheeler allowed to go underground you
have that's the medical rides I don't
want to know but what of what's really
happening is you're saying everyone has
to drive as slow as the 18-wheeler you
know you bring this moment now no that's
not true
on any given freeway for the troop no
any given freeway you have speed limit
all right some people drive over taken
care for your weight but here's what I'm
explaining what do people we want to
drive 100 miles per hour
there's no autumn on you know Lane Ron
United States limits wish there was well
then you can drive but but I'm not going
to answer for your insurance
I'm not going to make any of your
hospital bills a and yeah sure you'll
just be stuck in traffic with me here in
the Audubon line things there's no lab
so we're all stuck in traffic are we
stuck in traffic any more than we are
over we're stuck in traffic all the time
it wouldn't be as much traffic if people
weren't allowed to for example good
example be the car powerful I have more
people need to get through let's give
them priority sure shouldn't play them
in so of course with more oppressive
government regulation costs tend to rise
cause that the upstart small businessman
on the internet can't afford but the big
players can see maybe that's why giant
corporations like Google actually
support net neutrality we should not
allow it to be policed by for-profit
companies that's the support in the
government net neutrality like Google
the big corporations support it the mid
tier and lower businesses are against it
because they would be buried under the
costs like the smaller banks under the
New Deal where we created super banks
too big to fail so the too big to fail
companies all support net neutrality why
do you think that is I mean I think I
think there's a question I'm not sure I
wouldn't want to say I don't think that
I have that much insight into their
motivations for supporting net
neutrality sure it's expensive but not
as expensive as it is for the company
who doesn't have billions or millions of
dollars from which to draw and so those
companies closed their door competition
annihilated monopolies secured hey maybe
we could go back to the days where the
government gets to ordain and protect
monopolies like we used to do over 100
years ago oh that's more like a personal
opinion or theory I'm sure a guy like Al
Franken would dismiss me as nothing more
than a crazy that's why you're cheaper
here I'll go right here that elephant
is fighting for net neutrality and say
something like leave the internet alone
a stupid Tea Partiers listen I get that
net neutrality is an incredibly complex
issue that's why they'll give it a very
benign harmless name and then hit you
with a bunch of technical lingo to try
and confuse you into agreeing with them
and some of you very well may agree with
them and I understand that but I also
understand that the Internet is an
incredible tool that has possibly
revolutionized the world more than any
other in history and we've barely even
scratched the tip now can you think of
another example of free enterprise at
work benefiting the people at large
better than the internet because I
certainly can't
only
you know I come from a country where we
don't let for-profit companies run our
hospitals because we've worked out great
for Canada yes it has it's worked out
fabulously for Canada and Canadians
recently voted the creator of socialized
medicine in Canada the greatest Canadian
who ever lived so obviously the
Canadians are in general in favor of our
socialized medical it was publicly
declared a crisis and a violation of
Human Rights and shall we vs. get back
in 2005 from Claude cast okay the man
who headed up the Commission that
founded socialized medicine I'm sorry
you said that very quickly like in your
2005 a Supreme Court case shall we
versus Quebec it was declared a
violation of Human Rights because wait
times were so long and so many people
were dying that they opened it up to
privatization and that's why the Canada
you now have super hospitals ORS in the
states we know them hospitals